okay yeah all right it looks really
terrible okay if you're patient with it
you'll be fine and this is all in terms
of ten emotions okay so I'm not going to
use the sign a plus B expansion that I
used before I'm going to need the tan
expansion in a minute okay
so let's just pause and remember what is
tan a must be what's the extension equal
to it's all be the fraction remember
yeah tan is a good start good yeah
10 plus 10 1 minus 10 times tan okay if
you ever can't remember you know is a
plus or minus which way most people tend
to remember that you know if you have a
plus B that's gonna get bigger right if
you subtract they did say the double
angle formula right you get 10 a minus
1000 you know double any angle is equal
to 0 so that's how I remember that
there's a possible in the front okay all
right now keep that in the back of your
head how's that gonna apply to here and
this is a song question okay it's not
approve this identity this is not an
identity okay so I'm gonna try and have
to get these guys outside of the 10
inverse so that I can actually work with
them and then make X the subject okay
that's my goal right now there's
something else I was gonna say alright
okay because there's algebra here right
X's and fractions all that kind of thing
this is a classic example of where you
can't just use your packet up we
calculate will be no help here or the
previous kind of question it's all
numbers to calculate can handle that but
this is why you still need to know how
to do it without judgment okay so to get
all of us carry this out the way seems
like the most sensible thing to do is to
use 10 its sir 10 of everything left
hand side right hand side so I'm going
to go along hand
okay now even though you could probably
get away with in this question without
saying anything cuz it anything affects
it remember we were talking about sine
sine inverse sine is a sign and so on
okay I'm doing 10 a whole bunch of teddy
messes right so this is the kind of
scenario that I've gone okay
now do you remember what it was et -
right it's equal to X but in what domain
they remember how I tell now the domain
really depends on your inside function
because the inside function is what's
gonna make or break everything right so
what's the domain domain that's
horizontal of tan inverse it just goes
forever right
that's fine okay so therefore that's the
reason why I remember unlike sine of
sine inverse and cause of cos inverse
this is equal to X for all about it's
fine so I can actually at this point all
of my tangent an interest is will
exactly cancel okay so let's write the
right hand side first cuz it's a bit
easier
Tanner can you miss six on seven okay
left hand side even though it looks
terrible it's just 10 plus B right so
we're going to use my expansion up here
okay so I've got 10 on a which is tear
Tanis blog that's just blog okay plus
tan Oh tan inverse that and then on my
denominator 1 minus these two guys
and that's equal to that's equal to six
or seven okay so this yeah
you mean this like here all right you
mean like I just keep this line 22 right
that my new no which is why but that's
why I made a point of saying you know
where does this work and the answer is
all about so that's why it's not that
important that I sort of skip that step
because that step doesn't have any
tricky restrictions after watch out for
those columns I have to be a little more
careful you still might be able to get
away with you know not including it if
you were quite confident and you'd noted
any restrictions pluses and minuses in
that campaign but yeah I think you're
okay all right now it's just algebra
well admittedly I did mess this up I
just I just substituted this wrong okay
but the safest way to go about this to
get rid of these fractions on fractions
is just to multiply three by the most
appropriate common denominator which in
this case it looks to me like one minus
x squared okay so when I multiply upon
the top this is what I'm going to get
that's a plus one and when I multiply on
the bottom this will become 1 minus x
squared this is another name cancel and
that's all equal to 6/7 okay all right
let's go make like terms well I should
expand the top my suppose that's X minus
x squared okay so you can see quite a
lot of canceling is happening but you
really do have to be careful with your
brackets and that kind of thing like all
of the inverse trees over by this line
right so then just regular algebra takes
me just have to be careful X Squared's
cancel on the top this is 6 over 7
there's a factor of 2 on both sides so
I'll cancel that 2 and I'll make this 3
and now I'm in a position where I can
cross multiply so I'm getting 7x
get everything all on the one side and
now that's factorized okay so I want a
pair of numbers that add up to minus
sorry they multiply it to minus 18 and
they have to 7 multiplied to minus 18
add to 7 there aren't that many numbers
criminalizes 9 and minus 2 right ok so
I'm dividing my six sided get 36 x
squared at the end there's a 2 and a 3
that make that up the 3 is going to go
into here the twos gonna go into here
so this is going to become X plus 3 used
to become 3 X minus 1 and now I can
write my solutions out -
finished okay so yes yeah okay so this
heaps of different ways to do this sum
factorization right people do the cross
method the other quadratic that kind of
thing this is the method that I learned
it works from my head if doesn't work
for your head then just factorize this
however you like okay but that's the way
that works for me so that's